(mysterious noises)
Male 1: If I told you about her
M1: the princess without voice
M1: what would I say?
(enter reserved music)
(ringing bell gradually grows louder)
(click as an alarm is shut off)
(sounds occur in time with the music)
Female 1: Eliza! Come on!
F1: Eliza, hurry, hurry
(sounds occur in time with the music)
(loud bang)
(music immediately stops)
(soft bells begin playing)
Male 2: She deaf?
F1: Mute, sir; She can hear you.
M2 (sternly): You clean that lab, you get out.
(low drum hit as the screen cuts to black)
(water bubbling)
Male 3: This may very well be
M3: the most sensitive asset
M3: ever to be housed in this facility
(orchestra hit at scene change)
M2: You may think
M2: that thing looks human
M2: ...stands on 2 legs, right?
(water bubbles)
M2: ...but, we're created in the Lord's image
M2: You don't think that's what the
M2: the lord looks like, do-ya? [do you?]
Male 4: This creature is intelligent,
M4: capable of language,
M4: of understanding emotions.
(music suddenly fades)
(pleasant music plays)
(music begins to fade)
Male 5 (translating): "When he looks at me,"
M5: "he does not know"..."how"...
M5: ..."I am incomplete."
M5: "He"...
M5: ..."sees me"...
(pleasant music resumes)
M5: ..."as I am."
(French vocals join music)
(light splashing noises)
M2: The natives in the Amazon
M2: worshipped 'em, [them,]--
--(loud noise)--
M2: ...like a god.
(screeching noises)
M5: "Get him out"...
M5: What are you talking about?
M5: No! (disturbed chuckle)
(noise hit)
M2: We need to take it apart;
M2: Learn how it works.
(French vocals continue, mysteriously)
Male (apprehensive): I don't want an intricate,
Male: beautiful thing destroyed!
Other Male: We can do nothing!
Other Male: I'm sorry!
(drum hit)
F1: Don't do this, Eliza.
M2: What is she saying?!
(crash)
F1: Don't do this!
(noise builds)
M5 (gasping): It's not even human.
(loud orchestra hit)
(noise fades)
(silence and running water)
(underwater sounds)
M1: If I told you about her...
M1: ...what would I say? ...I wonder.
(French vocals and music return)
(music fades)
(silence)